Kohler just because you're playing metal
gear solid four doesn't mean you're good
as stealth yeah well then how did I
steal this box off a homeless guy smart
ass because he was dead smells in here
this thursday marked the release of
metal gear solid four considered by many
to be the first big exclusive killer app
for the playstation 3 it is again
following the adventures of super secret
agent Solid Snake only now this time
instead of sneaking through heavily
guarded military bases he's dropped
right in the middle of an active Middle
East war zone metal gear solid four from
what we've played so far really cranks
up the intensity on the series and so
for many people it's probably going to
be the reason that they buy a
Playstation 3 now if you haven't played
the first three Metal Gear Solid games
will you have any idea what's going on
with the story line probably not but let
me say this I have played the first
three Metal Gear Solid games and I have
no idea what the hell is happening in
this one anybody who tells you that they
know what happens in Metal Gear is
probably a liar the stories are so
filled with espionage counterespionage
triple agents and absurd plot twists
that it's difficult to keep it all
straight even as you're playing them but
damned if they're not awesome while
you're doing it then the voice acting is
incredible the cinematic work is
dramatic and intense the graphics are
gorgeous Metal Gear Solid 4 is even more
so now in case you're not quite sold I'm
going to give you a rundown of the
game's first hour so you can see just
how lovingly detailed just the first few
moments are your spoiler warning begins
right now now the first eight minutes of
your metal gear solid four experience
are going to be taken up by the game's
installation to the PlayStation 3's hard
disk which is currently going on right
in back of me it does take quite a while
and it's going to take off about 4.6
gigabytes if your PlayStation 3's hard
drive but while that's all voting you
get to watch Solid Snake smoking a whole
bunch of cigarettes in back of us and
using warnings and things like that
flash on the screen it's actually pretty
riveting for some reason you know it
does get you acclimated to just how nice
the game's graphics actually look once
you start the game the first thing you
see is a live-action TV interview with
David Hayter the voice of solid snake
what the hell if you start pressing the
control pad you can actually flick
through a whole bunch of different fake
shows like a bizarre cooking show and a
quiz show that takes place in hell what
is this there's no answer after swapping
through all these channels for a while
you're launched into the game itself
with no explanation as to what all that
was we then get this amazing opening
credit sequence that blends just a
little bit of interactive game play with
all the story exposition gradually
bringing you into the experience
introducing familiar characters like
your remote mission partner and link to
the outside world otakon and a whole
mess of different weapons and items for
snake fuse in his sneaking this time
around one key item an eye patch called
the solid i has a whole bunch of
different functions that help you make
sense of the world around you it brings
up a radar that shows you where threats
are and can also serve as a night-vision
aid slightly lower on the usefulness
scale is solid snakes iPod yeah a real
in-game ipod you can use it in the menu
to listen to music that you find all
over the world and change the game
soundtrack to your liking for example if
you want to use this theme from the
8-bit Metal Gear games as evidenced by
those crazy fake TV shows that preceded
the game Metal Gear Solid 4 does not
take itself too seriously yes it's got
serious message about the modern state
of war commentary on private military
corporations and but it's also got non
sequitur jokes it smashes the fourth
wall over and over it references his own
creator Hideo Kojima twice in the first
hour what struck me the most though
about this first little glimpse at Metal
Gear Solid 4 was that the game seems to
have been readjusted for more casual or
action-oriented gamers yes you can still
sneak through the world without being
detected but it's much easier to survive
now if you're caught because shooting
enemies is done in the years of war
style over-the-shoulder fashion so when
I was caught I just mowed my way through
the fighters very easily you know we've
only played no gear solid four for about
an hour so far but it's really an
amazingly polished experience and we're
all just blown away which is probably a
good thing because at the rate this
guy's chain-smoking there's probably not
going to be a metal gear solid 5
you